stop
he calls himself abracadabra you and I
have been enemies for years he said he
was from the future yes sixty fourth
century Georgia in a hand he has
information that will save irises like I
know senator greens
flash on this Tuesday at 8/7 central
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got to
talk about abracadabra on the flash this
is gonna be crazy but there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so this is
so cool if you didn't recognize him the
person who's playing abracadabra was in
the ant-man movie so you probably seen
at least one version of the character so
I'll talk about his history a little bit
but the TV shows being relatively true
to his origin story he's from the 64th
century he's a magician but really he
just has super advanced technology
because you have to imagine that the
reverse flash is from the 31st century
we've seen a lot of the cool toys that
he's brought back he's a genius in his
time what does that make him here that
was one of my favorite lines from the
first season
so abracadabra is from the 64th century
so you think that he'd be super advanced
way beyond the level of the
reverse-flash
but no the funny thing here is that it's
almost a Booster Gold typed twist he's
somebody who's underappreciated in his
own time he wants to be a magician and
perform for people so he brings his
technology back to present-day so that
he has a crowd to perform for he was
created during the Silver Age during
Barry Allen's run by carmine infantino
he's one of the people that created most
of the classic rogue so like Captain
cold weather wizard all the people that
you saw way back in the first season of
the flash those are all carmine
infantino characters the first time he
bought him he ran by a poster for an
abracadabra performance and got turned
into a marionette and used in his
performance so the flash had to find a
way to reverse his rate so it's all
technology-based but abracadabra just
has this sense of theatricality that
just gets a little bit ridiculous but in
the episode you see he's an earth 19
character so it's team flash going to
help gypsy take him down and surprise
surprise if flash lets him go he'll tell
him who sabotage is so it's a big moral
conundrum for Barry this is gonna be a
big thing for Barry through the rest of
the season
does he take the quick and easy route to
taking Sabbat are down it will that lead
him closer to unleashing sava tarp
because it sounds like we're going to
witness the birth of savitur eventually
like as we slowly learn who he is we get
more clues we're actually gonna see it
unfold on screen remember we just got
that big twist with Barry at the end of
the last episode
where he proposed iris so they're
implying that they're gonna get married
at some point in the show's future maybe
not this season if not in a future
season there was a very late Mark Waid
era flash story where abracadabra comes
in steals Linda Park as she's getting
ready to get married to Wally West in
Heights or they're light years away from
using a twist like that on the TV show
but that would be funny if Barry and
iris eventually get married and then
somebody shows up and just whisks her
away like nope not gonna marry today but
he actually pretends to be the
reverse-flash when he does it so is this
really crazy Mark Waid twist Merck Way
tells some of the best crazy comic book
stories they've been doing that a lot
this year where they go to earth 19 so
it makes me wonder if they might
eventually make gypsy a more series
regular character maybe not full series
regular but more recurring if you ever
wonder why they have like a really cool
character that comes on like they
brought golden glider on and they kind
of put Cisco with her character but then
you never see her again
it's usually some behind-the-scenes
thing because if it's a good character
they always try to bring him back as
much as possible so unless like gypsy
gets cast on another TV show hopefully
we'll see her more next season but I
think they're trying to sidestep the
problem of just making her Cisco's
girlfriend because it's like we know why
is she around if she has the same powers
as Cisco is there something that she can
do that Cisco can't do there has to be a
logical reason for her to be on the team
she has to serve some purpose that's not
filled by another member so it'll
probably happen is is they'll use her to
surface more cool comic book stories
next season where she's just tracking
down breachers in the breacher that she
tracks down just happens to be like a
brand new really cool comic book
character that we haven't seen before we
only got about five episodes left and I
think last year we had found out who
zoom was around this time within this
block of episodes so whoever he is there
are so many theories there are a lot of
theories pointed to Barry Allen now
there's still some evidence to support
some other characters but it sounds like
they've been culminating towards Barry
becoming the villain so I'm slowly
coming around to that theory because if
you didn't see my flash video from last
night I used a flashpoint clip or
reverse flash is cursing Barry Allen is
the villain of the story in the more and
more I'm thinking about I'm like ooh
wouldn't it be awesome if they called
out who the villain was in that very
first episode but even if Barry doesn't
take the
bate they'll still be a bunch more clues
the really cool thing about abracadabra
in the comics right now if you haven't
been keeping up with rebirth is they
tied him to Wally West character the
ginger Wally West so pre flashpoint
ginger Wally West comes back and nobody
knows why he disappeared for ten years
his way of explaining why he wasn't
around during the new 52 in their quest
to find out what happened to those 10
missing years they unwittingly unleashed
abracadabra in present-day whose
consciousness was hidden in another
person and he reveals that he was
responsible for Wally disappearing so he
only takes credit for that he's not
responsible for all of this DC rebirth
craziness that's a much bigger thing
that's gonna be revealed when Geoff
Johns does his dr. Manhattan comic book
later this year so I'm really excited to
find out what's going on there but
because this is the first time we've
seen him on the TV show just expect him
to make some crazy escape so that he can
come back and be crazy again next year
because if you noticed there's been like
a trend the last two seasons on the
flash it's like the guest stars just get
a little bit better every time they
bring someone on so they tend to bring
those characters back like if it's a
really good actor or they have a really
good experience or it's like a relic rod
and everybody just wants them on all the
time cuz he's such an interesting
character the really cool thing about
the flash that's different from a lot of
other DC characters especially Green
Arrow characters is that his rogues
gallery is almost as big as Batman's
rogues gallery so he has so many more
characters to pick from that they
haven't done on the TV show yet so once
we get through the rest of the season we
can start talking about season four
characters we want them to bring on
because even without bringing back
people they've already done that we're
really cool there is this bottomless
well of Flash characters so the really
cool thing you may have noticed is that
there is a lot of time-travel stuff
that's happening in the back half of the
season barry going to the future other
people besides reverse-flash from the
future coming back so that might
continue to be a big thing in season 4
what a coincidence though that Cisco's
go to reference line this week is jr.
talking when they just did the Tolkien
character on legends of tomorrow they
actually did a really good job with him
too he wasn't as big a character as I
expected but I'll talk about that when I
post my legends of tomorrow video so
reverse-flash is now the god of the DC
universe be afraid
be very afraid so that video should post
in the next couple hours - after I post
this congratulations Jerell Lawrence
you're the new giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel there was a new round that
started in this video I'll remind
everyone when I post that legends of
tomorrow video in a little while while
you wait for that click here for my
flash episode from last night and click
here for my iron fist ending in season 2
explainer video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys in that next video